hi there today we'll look at big bird
transformers for longer sequences by
manil zaire and guru garuganesh at
al of google research so this paper on a
high level proposes to
replace the quadratic attention
mechanism in transformers by
a mix of random attention
windowed attention and selective global
attention therefore achieving a
complexity
of linear memory requirement instead of
quadratic
memory requirement and as a result of
that they can process
longer sequences than traditional
transformers like bert
and achieve better results in some nlp
tasks
and they also evaluate on genomics tasks
so we'll go
through this paper a bit look a bit at
the proof because they give a
theoretical
kind of guarantee that their random
attention mechanism can still
be touring complete and can still
achieve the same things as a full
attention mechanism
but we'll also look at the drawbacks i
sort of have mixed feelings about this
paper
and i think i'll voice my concerns as we
go
through here but first let's look at the
paper let's look at the architecture
and i think this is actually a pretty
cool paper for
the empirical progression of the field
to
process longer sequences with
transformers
as always if you like content like this
uh feel free to
share it around uh leave a like and tell
me in the comments what you think
about the paper and about what i think
whatever you just just uh go nuts
all right so the basic
uh the basic premise right here is that
the transformers they've been
pretty impactful especially in nlp so
they say transformer based models such
as bert
have been one of the most successful
deep learning models for
nlp unfortunately one of their core
limitations is the quadratic dependency
mainly in terms of memory on the
sequence length due to their full
attention mechanism so
really briefly the full attention
mechanism and i've done
you know numerous videos about attention
mechanism bert
attention is all you need and so on so
if you want a detailed explanation of
what that is just
go look up the corresponding videos but
briefly
what you'll have in nlp is a set of
tokens
a sequence of tokens as an input and you
want to
transform them layer after layer into
sort of a a higher order representation
of that
same sequence and for that you build
these layers
out of nodes and you have as many nodes
usually as you have tokens in the
sequence
and the next set of so each token
is represented by a vector at the
beginning
and each layer transforms this sequence
as i said into
sort of a higher level representation so
you want the vector
of this token right here um to be a
better representation than the vector
was right here
and you do that by incorporating
information from
all the other tokens into that
particular vector now as i said this is
called an attention mechanism
and we don't actually have to go into
how it works right here but you can see
pretty clearly that
if you want to do this for every token
you need to have information routed from
every token to every token like from
here to here
from here to here and so on and this is
just one
token and then you need to do it for
this token and for this token and for
this token
so what you'll ultimately get if n is
your sequence length
you'll get some n squared amount of
computation and
memory requirements for this so this is
a problem
and usually this means that you know
this sequence length in bert
this is limited to something like 512
tokens which is okay for some
applications but if you want to
summarize you know entire articles
entire books even
or do question answering with lots of
context
it's not really enough so people have
been thinking about how to
scale this input how to scale
this and of course the main culprit is
this quadratic
tension mechanism because if you you
know double the 512 you need
you know four times the amount of
compute and memory
so how does this paper go about
reducing that quadratic dependency the
goal right here
is of course to get this to some o of n
right because then as we double the
input length we simply need to double
the compute requirements and that would
be fantastic and that's what this paper
does and it does so without you know
sacrificing
the properties of the transformer so
here's the
architecture that big bird proposes
by the way big bird another character
from
sesame street i guess will continue the
naming here after elmo and bert
you know i i'm i'm waiting for the model
that's the count um yeah
that's going to be a fun model but so
big
bird basically has three different types
of attention and here
these are adjacency matrices in this
attention mechanism so here is the
input layer and the output layer
is right here so that basically means
that node
i right here would be connected well
sorry
that's not a straight line would be
connected to
this particular node and also to this
particular node
so we're now trying if we have
node i right here we're now trying to
not
connect it to all of these nodes
but we'll say we'll just select sum
at random and then connect it to that
okay this is what we call
random attention and you can pretty
clearly see
if you connect each of the i nodes to
r equals two to two random nodes then
you don't have
an n squared anymore but you'll have
a like an o of r times
n which you know if r is a constant is
an o of n
attention mechanism okay so
the main goal between the random
attention mechanism is
that for each query basically you select
random tokens that you attend to
and that random number is a fixed number
that's not dependent on the sequence
length
and the paper is a little bit unclear
about whether or not those random ones
are the same
for every sequence or are switched up or
are the same for every layer or are
switched up
but they formulate all of this as sort
of in sort of a graph in sort of a
random graph
so there they formulate the attention
mechanism in form of a graph
so if we transform all of these nodes
into a graph
a full attention mechanism would mean
that each graph
each node is connected to each of the
other nodes right
fully connected graph i don't
maybe that's it
so that would be a full attention
mechanism and then they say well
if we just have random connections
between these things
then there are some theorems from graph
theory that say
that each random walk in this graph is
going to
um so this graph is going to mix pretty
quickly so i can get from each node to
each other node
by a random walk in a logarithmic time
and this random walk which basically
means that you go from here
to here this would be one layer of the
transformer
and then if you want to go from here to
here that would you would have to do
that in the next layer so this
formulation as a random graph leads me
to believe
that layer after layer the random
attention pattern is going to be
the same but also the formulation of the
paper leads me to believe that
the this random attention differs from
sequence to sequence so
i believe what's happening is that they
you know get a new sequence
then they decide on this pattern right
here
once and then they use this layer after
layer the same pattern again
so you can see that um in the
traditional attention information can
basically throw
flow from each of the nodes to each
other node
in one single step right because each
node is connected to each other node
you see this in the graph right here
however
if we only select a subset then
you know it needs to if if i want to go
from as i said from here to here then i
need to do it in two
steps and therefore i need two layers
and that's going to be the culprit of
this method here
and you know while it is mentioned in
the paper it's sort of
i feel at least that's my my assessment
of this paper it's kind of swept under
the rug a little bit i mean they do have
a theorem
that clearly says we can construct an
example
of a task that in the full attention
setting can be solved with
a single step so a single layer that in
our
random attention setting needs a lot of
layers so a lot of steps
but you know the rest of the paper is
sort of shaky
on on this thing but nevertheless you
can see
how the random attention can if you have
enough
layers do the same information routing
as the full
attention okay however this is not a
property of the random attention
and we'll see this in the next thing
right here so the next ingredient that
this paper uses is
window attention and you can see over
here that
big bird is ultimately going to be a
combination of the three types of
attention
which will uh which we are looking at
here so
window attention basically means that
each
each eye each token at the if position
is going to attend
to itself of course so here is
i but it is also going to attend to its
neighbors so here is
i minus 1 and here is i plus 1. and this
is a you know this is a window size w
that you can that is a parameter but
also
it is a constant and therefore um you
again go from n squared to w times n
which you know is o of n if w is a
constant
and this might be familiar to you
because we've already seen this in the
long former paper so i've made a video
or base
i think even two videos on the long
former
which used exactly the window attention
in combination with the global attention
and uh if you want to know more about
that go watch these videos
but the new thing in big bird right here
is this
re edition of the random attention
again the the window here
in is is has exactly the same properties
as the random attention
so you have instead of a fully connected
graph
you have a sparsely connected graph now
if you have random attention the
sparsely connected graph is like
like the one on the right but if you
have a windowed attention
you can it is kind of not randomly
connected
but each node is connected to its
neighbors like this
and you can also see that if i want to
go from this node
to this node right here i can't do it in
one step but i can do it in two
steps i go here and i go here
so in the terms of the attention layers
if i want to
go from node one to node three
i have to do it in two steps because
each node is only connected to its
neighbors
so the connection patterns would sort of
look like
this so i have to go
from one to two and then in the next
layer from
two to three so the paper basically
makes up for the lack of full attention
by
uh adding layers and you also might
recognize this from a convolution
operation
like this basically because it is a
convolution operation right in a
convolution
each node a only aggregates input
from its neighbors for the next layer
and then we know that as we go
up the layers the de facto window that
each node looks at
is going to be like a cone kind of like
this
so this is very similar to how a
convolutional neural network works and
the reasoning is very similar
because the reasoning is well in a
sentence
the most important words for any given
word
are probably going to be its neighbors
like the words around it
and as you go up the layers you branch
out
more and more but ultimately the this
neighborhood
principle holds in nlp as well
so again we already saw this in the long
former
but that's the reason behind the window
attention and that's the second
ingredient
and then the third ingredient is this
global attention
now the global attention uh is
selected tokens that are so important
and that's you know fixed by the
developers that are so
important that they are they are
connected to everything else
so for example in these transformers you
often
have what's you know this kind of cls
token so this is a special token that
you prepend
to some piece of text and the output of
this token is going to be your
classification output because
you don't want to bind your
classification if you need to classify
the entire sequence you don't want to
bind that decision to
one particular word what you want to do
is you want to have an
extra token and that's this cls token
that kind of aggregates information from
all of this so layer after layer layer
after layer
you'll have so if we go here layer after
layer we have this
one special node and in each step
every single other node is able to send
information right here to this node
and receive information from this node
okay so now uh
as a result of this as you as you may be
able to see
every single uh every single path
is kind of a maximum length of two
because if i want to go
from any node to any other node i can
simply you know
send information to this global node and
then the global node in the next
step can send information to whatever
other
node and that is a property that they
use in their proof
that this tension mechanism is as
sort of as powerful as the classic full
attention mechanism and we'll go
through that in one second but first i
hope this was clear that
this combination of random attention
window attention and global attention
is what is called big
bird okay they have some engineering
tricks that go along with this but
in concept you can imagine big bird
being long former
plus these random attention right here
and you know as an engineer as an nlp
engineer that makes
kind of total sense i you know i totally
believe
that a the introduction the addition of
these random
attention of these random attention
patterns can
absolutely help your classification
or whatever your nlp tasks because
you know more attention better and i
also
am completely willing to believe that
you know using the full
attention matrix while it is of course
more accurate it won't hurt too much to
leave some of that attention away
because essentially all the path lengths
are just becoming
too or even with the random attention
are really short or logarithmic
to route information from a node to some
other node
so the loss that you incur
is kind of in a logarithmic scale in
terms of performance
while the gain that you make is sort of
in a
in a quadratic or like a linear scale
you go from quadratic
to linear and that seems to me like a
good
empirical trade-off all right however
the the proofs here the
proof of um of
how how these how these things are
constructed
are a little bit i don't know so
what they do in the proof that this
function
can sort of a is a universal
approximator
people have already shown that full
attention mechanisms are universal
approximators
um so they show here that this sparse
attention mechanism is also a universal
approximator they make big use of star
graphs what they say is okay if we have
a star
graph which is one node connected right
here to
every other node this is a star graph
if we have a star graph we can achieve
the same thing than with a full graph a
full graph is where every node is
connected to every other node
but as i already said what they need for
this
is multiple layers of this star graph so
and that has to do with the fact that if
i want to route information
i basically have to go via this
middle node right here and there's an
additional complication because this
middle node
in our case right here is only one node
i can't route information at the same t
like i can't
have this routing right here at the same
time
that i have this routing right here like
going from here
to here because i only have one middle
node and
i kind of this is not how the like this
is very dumb
math but uh maybe you have to imagine
that
there is one memory slot and
you can only use that one memory slot at
the same time
for one of these things so essentially
what you'll have to do is you'll have to
do the green thing first and then in the
next step you'll have to do
the blue thing second and then
so these are now pairwise routing
between nodes
but ultimately what an attention
mechanism does is it does
everything to everything right in a
single layer it routes information from
all the nodes to all the other nodes
and to achieve that so you need multiple
rounds of this and it turns out that in
the worst case
you actually need n rounds of this so
you know you trade off your you go from
n square to n uh memory and compute
requirements in a single layer
but in the worst case you need n layers
to recover
the the power of the full trend of the
full transformer
and that is the last one of their
theoretical
results right here so first they prove
universal approximations
and second they prove turing
completeness these two properties have
been proven for
full attention mechanisms and third
they prove that there are tasks where
you actually do need
n layers to solve them with their
limited attention
um so
you know i'm not sure but i i feel you
can make
any sort of polynomial uh algorithm
into a linear algorithm like this like i
have a i have like a cool sorting
algorithm right
so if this is my sequence that i want to
sort what i can do
is i can simply you know take a random
subset of them
uh like this this and this and then kind
of go and
and sort them and then put them like i
send them to the
to the global memory like this i sort
them
and then i put them back right
and if i do this for enough
if i do this for enough rounds okay you
know if i do this for enough rounds you
know at the worst case i need
n rounds to sort my or log n rounds if i
do it smartly
but you know in you know the single step
here
is uh the single step is just o
of n so i have now an o of n sorting
algorithm
i you know i have my sort of
a bit of wary to express things like
that
and um yeah but
you know it is from an empirical
standpoint i absolutely believe that
this uh this is enough
now my second quarrel right here is that
if you
look at the proof first of all what it
makes use is this star graph
and the star graph corresponds to the
global attention
so that's not much to do with the random
attention though they use the random
intention in their proof but
i at least believe that it would be
possible
with the global attention only
and then the second thing is if you look
at the parameters
that they use for the um
for the experiments and i've already set
this in the long former
video so in the long former video it
turned out
that if you look at how big this window
attention
is it turns out that it
you're still well you know the original
bert attended to
512 tokens and then you look at the
window and the window was
still 512 tokens it's just that the
global attention was even more so
ultimately they ended up using more
memory than the original
bird and here if i look at the
parameters
of their um thing
and they have multiple experiments right
here and i believe this is the
the base version so this is the base
version they also have this large
version but here this is the 12
layer um version and you can see they
have this block
length and we'll get into the block
length
in one second but then you can see that
their window
size is three times the block length the
number of random tokens is three times
the block length and the number of
global tokens is two times the block
length
so that results in eight times b so
8 times 64 is you know
can i calculate this or am i stupid
uh it's 512 yes actually calculated this
before
so this is 512 tokens so
you know you you go from from bert that
has 512 tokens and
attends to 512 tokens to also
attending to 512 tokens of course the
advantage here is that
they now have 4 009
and 96 sequence length so they have the
freedom
to not attend to as many tokens as they
have in the input length
but you know to put it in perspective
this
here uses more memory and more compute
on it on its face than bert
because bert attends to as many tokens
but has a smaller
input sequence
and you know i i there's sort of a thing
where
in order to make these sparse attention
things
work you have to go pretty pretty you
know high in the number of things you
attend to
you can leave away some but it's not
like you can you know scale up
orders of magnitude of your input
sequence length
so that's this promise of linear
attention
is sort of it's kind of fulfilled but
not there yet
the second thing i i would like to point
out is that
in a lot of cases the number of random
tokens is actually set to zero
so really making use i believe of these
of the of the global of the number of
global tokens
so it's that seems a bit strange in that
they
continuously refer to their random
attention mechanism
um but then in a lot of experiments they
don't actually have a random
attention mechanism i believe they have
to do that because that's kind of what
makes them different from the long
former
in principle but still um
yeah so the last
novelty let's say is an engineering
novelty in that
they now always consider not single for
example they don't consider
single random attention they always
consider these in blocks
and that's because our current hardware
is really bad at sparse
stuff really bad at
single indexing gathering single things
so
if you can do everything in blocks you
basically
get you get these blocks almost for free
so
it takes only marginally longer to
retrieve this full two by two block
right here than it would to retrieve the
single uh instance right here of course
that
means you have you know four times you
still use four times more memory
but it is not four times slower than the
original thing so
you can use these blocks uh right here
you can do it for the random attention
you can do it for the window attention
as you can see here so you break this
window pattern a little bit
into blocks and that makes it
a lot faster or that speeds up i get the
speed up
almost for free and then they make
another approximation
in that the way they do this
windowing is and now let's just go
really briefly so
you can see right here that
it would be very cumbersome to gather so
what we need we're just going to focus
this
this dotted thing right here is a bit
confusing so
you want to attend to these things and
these you can just get out with a matrix
slice really easy
but then you want to attend to this kind
of blocky
thing right here from the window
attention right like this thing
and this is hard to get out because
you'd have to kind of
index each row individually and that's
very slow
so what they do there is this matrix
roll operation
where you can sort of roll the axis
around so what you'll do is you'll take
this thing right here and you put it to
the left
right here and you'll take for example
this thing right here
and you'll put it to the right or
no like it's it's up and down but in
essence that's what you do
and you can you can fold all of this
blue stuff
into a rectangular matrix if you
know if you can see right here so you
kind of
roll this back roll this back roll this
forward
and you replace whatever is missing
by these now this again gives you some
inaccuracies because
this block right here was never intended
to be attended
to and all of a sudden you see you have
the k6
in here so it gives you a bit of
inaccuracies at the edges
of the sequence but you can take that
you know you can take that hit for the
increased performance that you gain by
now having a
rectangular matrix tpus are really
efficient at this not as efficient
as this and then the only thing that's
really slow is gathering these
random blocks right here but also
by having the same amount of random
blocks per input token
what you'll do is you'll end up with
just one
of these columns right here or you know
r of these columns
and that again gives you a rectangular
matrix so this thing
right here you can process very very
efficiently using a
tpu and you know the mistakes you make
are basically
this thing right here and this thing
right here
because those weren't intended and are
at the edges of the sequence
so these were the the tricks of big bird
to
quickly uh summarize uh big bird
is basically taking a transformer
saying well why do we need all of this
attention
all of this full attention maybe we only
need
some of that and can already do a big
job a good job
especially you know considering the
attention mechanism goes over
multiple layers so we don't need a
routing from each token to each token
we we can make up for not having a fully
connected graph by simply
running multiple layers so
their sparsity is first of all you have
this random attention
which i believe changes from sequence to
sequence
but stays within or among the layers of
the same sequence
then you have the window attention with
the reasoning
so the reasoning behind the random
attention is that if you have a randomly
connected
graph the path lengths are on average
logarithmic
so you can route information efficiently
the reasoning behind the window
attention is that
probably neighbor information is very
important and that has been shown
empirically
and then the global attention the
reasoning behind this is that
some of the tokens that are fixed by the
developers are so important
that it it's very beneficial that each
other node
is connected to them and that they are
connected to each other node
the result of that is the big bird
attention mechanism which is basically
long former which already had these two
plus the random attention
this achieves a linear
linear complexity in terms of of memory
and compute though linear
has to be qualified a bit because it's
modified by
the window size by the number of random
attention
tokens by the number of global tokens
and in practice often ends up being you
know
fairly large-ish
and also the the theoretical guarantees
now
come with the fact that you need
multiple layers in the worst case you
need
sequence length amount of layers which
you know in the worst case would result
right back
into a quadratic requirement for memory
and compute
they do some engineering
some engineering tricks right here and
their
results are pretty good so
the results in various tasks and we'll
we'll look at some of the tasks right
here
so these are def set
results using base size models for
example where you can see
they do outperform basic roberta models
they outperform
long former which may mean that the
random attention is useful but
you know in these things it also always
may
just mean that you've thrown more
compute at it
um at least i'm not really looking that
they outperform the models because as
you can see right here if they compare
to state of the art
and you know granted these are models
that have been trained specifically
for these tasks and are you know crafted
and engineered
and big bird manages to big bird manages
to
hold itself against them in a lot of
tasks and even gets state of the art
on some what i'm more interested in is
that it
you know it can reach good numbers it
doesn't necessarily have to be state of
the art but it can
reach good numbers which tells me that
okay probably the the empirical hit that
i take by not having the full attention
is you know is justifiable by the speed
up
and memory savings i do get
um yeah especially when result when you
see results mixed like this you know
sometimes the
other model is good and sometimes the
big bird is good
on different variations and so on i
would not
you know i would not make a big deal out
of the fact that it is state of the art
i get that the authors have to do that i
would do so as well
but you know um you know don't
don't think that this is the like the
best thing
now uh it's very probable they just
thrown also
a lot of compute at it what is cool is
they do
uh some genomics experiments so not only
do they have
nlp state of the art but also they go
into genomics
and experiment with data there don't
want to
go into that because you know ultimately
it's another task and that we leave the
papers about the architecture
all right so that was big bird
i hope you enjoyed this video and
learned
i learned something certainly
if you want to check out the proofs
they're actually pretty entertaining
to read and yeah
i'll see you next time bye bye